et mieux se former merci madame la
ministre la parole l'état monsieur
pascal thévenot
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre je me souviens encore
de votre discours d'ouverture de
l'université d'été du medef en 2015 vous
affirmiez que je cite la france a besoin
de ces entreprises
car ce sont elles qui créent la richesse
ce sont elles qui créent l'emploi
vous mentionnez aussi qu'elle contribue
à l'aménagement est la cohésion de notre
territoire
pour conclure par ce propos j'aime
l'entreprise mais depuis le débat sera
du travail plus rien voix unie c'est
autour de la table des négociations les
représentants des syndicats étudiants
la cgpme et le medef pour n'écouter in
fine et que le président de l'unef qui à
27 ans est toujours étudiant en économie
sociale et solidaire
monsieur le premier ministre vous savez
que si 90 % des embauches se font cdd
c'est parce que le cdi fait peur aux pme
ce n'est en rien corrélé au cou du cdd
qui est déjà surtaxé de plus de 7% pour
les courtes durées alors pourquoi vous
immiscer deux forces dans les
discussions des partenaires sociaux qui
sont pourtant seuls à détenir la
responsabilité du financement de
l'assurance chômage
l'improvisation de votre annonce a même
provoqué un désordre d'ampleur au sein
de vos rangs votre ministre de
l'éducation nationale parler de bonus
malus quand le président de la
république lui déclarait que rien ne
changerait dans la taxation du cdd
monsieur le premier ministre les mesures
visant à ranger rire l' embauche en cdd
n'ont permis ni d'endiguer leur
progression dit améliorer le financement
de l'assurance chômage
pire elles ont eu pour effet des effets
néfastes sur l'emploi et la
compétitivité française
quelles raisons vous pousse donc à
penser que cette mesure aurait
aujourd'hui c'est la visite à madame
myriam el khomri ministre du travail
de l'emploi de la formation
professionnelle du dialogue social merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
pascal thévenot
en effet les partenaires sociaux il y a
trois ans à travers la nuit on
souhaitait moduler les cotisations
d'assurance chômage c'est-à-dire exonéré
partiellement pour trois à quatre mois
selon la taille des entreprises
lorsqu'il ya un recrutement en cdi
depuis d'un jeune de 26 ans et en même
temps appliquer une surcotisation pour
les cdd
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que il y à
un bilan bien sûr amener de cette
expérimentation l'avait été après
inscrite dans la loi
sécurisation de l'emploi et bien
évidemment ce qu'a dit le premier
ministre je tiens ici à le rappeler
c'est que les modalités pratiques de
cette modulation relève et relèveront
toujours des partenaires sociaux mais je
crois qu'il est important de se dire
entre nous que nous avons dans notre
pays
en effet une problématique qui sont les
cdd particulièrement court je vais vous
donner quelques chiffres
le premier c'est que 70% des cdd dans
notre pays sont des cdd de moins d'un
mois
pire 50 % le sont de moins d'une semaine
et quand vous courrez l'easa le fait que
82 % des embauches en cdd sont des ré
embauche vous pouvez à me l'imaginer
pour toutes ces personnes qui
collectionne des contrats
particulièrement courts avec des
périodes de chômage qu'il y a à la fois
une difficulté d'accès au crédit d'accès
au logement et que donc l'enjeu de cette
réflexion qui est actuellement menée par
les partenaires sociaux et devoir de
tirer les premières expériences 2,7 sur
cotisation de cette modulation qui a été
mise en oeuvre
nous ne parlons pas de surprise à sion
nous parlons de modulation en effet et
de voir si il faut aller en deçà de du
cdd de plus d'un mois et d'essayer de
mettre une modulation par rapport à des
cdd qui sont encore plus qu donc le
gouvernement ce qu'il proposera parce
que je sais je voudrais réussir est sûre
et l'ensemble des députés aussi
l'ensemble des employeurs notre pays a
besoin des cdd mais il y à une hyper
précarité et donc le gouvernement donne
un signal politique en disant dans un
article qui sera discuté bien évidemment
avec l'ensemble des parlementaires qu'au
lieu d'avoir cette possibilité de
moduler cette possibilité nous
souhaiterions la rendre obligatoire
merci la séance d'un cube vous